Bitte schön. Guten Tag. Ich möchte mir kurz vorstellen. Mein Name ist Rahme Kuck.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf dieser Station und würde mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit entstanden? Ja, natürlich.
Wobei, aufnahmens, vielleicht will ich gar nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Wir müssen ja mal gucken, was überhaupt los ist mit mir.
Ich wollte mich nur vorstellen wegen meiner Schmerzen.
Okay, okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Hans Weber. Hans? Hans ist der Vorname, männlich.
Und Weber ist der Familienname.
Okay, okay. Würden Sie bitte eher vor und nach Namen, naksam ustabilen.
Ja, H-A-N-S ist der Vorname.
Und W-E-B-I-R ist der Familienname.
Okay, beide sind wie Emil.
Bitte?
Wie?
Wie wie Emil?
Okay, gut. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 64 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 16.04.58.
58.
50, ja.
16.04.1908.
16.04.58.
Okay, gut. Wie schwer sind Sie?
82 kg, glaube ich, wieg ich so ziemlich genau.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie, Herr Weber?
187, bin ich.
187.
Okay, vielen Dank für alle Informationen, Herr Weber.
Welche Beschwerden führen Sie hierher?
Was kann ich für?
Ja, also ich habe solche Schmerzen in den Beinen.
Und das wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Bein.
Bitte?
Ihr Bein, oder?
Ja, also insbesondere im rechten Bein ist das ganz unangenehm.
Wenn ich eine Weile gelaufen bin,
dann muss ich mit einem stehen bleiben,
weil ich solche Schmerzen habe,
dass ich gar nicht mehr weiterlaufen kann.
Wenn ich einen Moment gestanden bin,
dann muss ich richtig Luft holen,
dann werden die Schmerzen wieder besser.
Und dann kann ich weiterlaufen.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen so stark,
dass ich gedacht habe, ich muss mich jetzt doch mal bei Ihnen melden.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe, Herr Weber,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, wobei 1, 1.
Oh, das sind schon tüchtige Schmerzen.
Also ich kann dann wirklich nicht weiterlaufen,
ich muss stehen bleiben.
Wenn wir sagen 1 bis 10, also je nachdem,
wenn es anfängt, nur 6 und 6,
aber wenn ich dann nicht stehenbleibe und weiterlaufe,
dann gehen die bis zu 8, würde ich sagen.
Ach so, okay, in Ruhe 6 beim Laufen.
Nein, nein, nein, in Ruhe, wenn ich nichts mache,
dann habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ach so, okay.
Ich habe Schmerzen nur, wenn ich laufe.
Aber das fängt langsam an und dann wird es mehr.
Okay, mit die 6 anfängt,
anfängt bis 8.
Ja?
Okay, vielleicht seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, dass die so stark sind,
das ist jetzt erst seit einigen Tagen,
aber an mir fangen wir schon vor einigen Wochen.
Okay.
Vor ein paar Wochen haben die...
Ja, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ist das auch schon,
ja, das war schon vor Weihnachten eigentlich,
also, dass ich gemerkt habe, dass das nicht mehr so gut geht.
Aber, ja, dann habe ich das irgendwie nicht so ernst genommen,
aber jetzt wird es halt immer schlimmer.
Ja, meinen Sie, dass Sie circa seit drei Monaten diese Beschwerden haben?
Ja, das kommt vielleicht schon hin, ja.
Drei Monate, aber seit ein paar Tagen haben...
Ist es schlechter, ja.
Okay, aber nur haben Sie die Schmerzen beim Laufen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, also Sie haben gesagt, Herr Weber,
dass Sie beim Laufen sehr starke Schmerzen haben,
deswegen müssen Sie eine Pause einlegen.
Genau.
Ach, welche Gehstrecke müssen Sie die Pause machen?
Ich meine, über 200 Meter oder unter 200 Meter?
Wie viel ist 200 Meter?
Also, wenn ich bei mir zum Kaufmann gehe,
das ist vielleicht ein halber Kilometer.
Ja, so.
Ja, dann so gut nach der Hälfte muss ich dann schon mal eine Pause einlegen, ja.
Okay, ich finde das auch...
Das sind vielleicht schon so 300 Meter, ja.
Okay, circa 300 Meter.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Und Sie haben Luftnot?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, Sie haben keinen Luftnot?
Nein, nein.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sehr gut.
Ja, haben Sie an der betroffenen Stelle am rechten Bein,
wie zum Beispiel glänzende Haut oder Haarausfall bemerkt?
Ja, das ist mir tatsächlich aufgefallen.
Da habe ich mir aber noch gar keine Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, woher wissen Sie das?
Ja, also da habe ich tatsächlich gemerkt, dass da die Haare weggehen
und das Bein fühlt sich auch irgendwie ein bisschen kühler an als das andere.
Ach so, okay.
Sie haben auch Haarausfall bemerkt
und Sie fühlen sich ein bisschen kalt?
Mhm, genau.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und ja, glänzende Haut, auch haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen anders aus, ja?
Mhm, ja, okay.
Sie, also haben Sie die Beschwerde nur am rechten Bein
oder auch linker Seite?
Nein, eigentlich nur am rechten Bein.
Mhm.
Okay, nur am rechten Bein.
Gut, okay.
Ja, Herr Weber, ja, möten Sie noch etwas ergänzen
oder ist das alles?
Ja, das langt mir völlig.
Okay, okay.
Und ich möchte jetzt über Ihren Allgemeinszustand bespähen.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber oder Schüttelfrost?
Nein, das habe ich zum Glück nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Ja, also ich bin ein bisschen verstopft.
Da muss ich schon immer ein bisschen aufpassen.
Wenn ich, ja, da muss ich halt irgendwie leinsamen Essen
oder Trockenflaumen oder irgendwie etwas,
damit ich auf die Toilette gehen kann.
Das ist schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Okay, okay, ich kann gut verstehen.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Probleme.
Wann haben Sie die Verstoffung, Herr Weber?
Seit wann haben Sie?
Oh, das habe ich schon lange.
Ich habe bestimmt schon 20 Jahre,
dass ich da ein bisschen aufpassen möchte.
Okay, wie gehen Sie damit um?
Nehmen Sie illegitwärlhe Medikamente ein?
Nein, mit so spezieller Ernährung,
was halt ein bisschen dafür sorgt,
dass man auf die Toilette gehen kann.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Probleme ein oder du zu schlafen?
Nein, meistens nicht.
Aber jetzt zur Zeit ist es schon manchmal so,
dass ich aufwache,
weil mir irgendwie das Bein dann,
ja, vielleicht doch irgendwie sich komisch anfühlt in der Nacht.
Ja, und manchmal muss ich auch auf die Toilette.
In meinem Alter ist es ja kein Wunder,
aber das ist jetzt nicht jede Nacht.
Okay, nicht jede Nacht, aber manchmal in der Toilette.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Und hat Sie Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein, ich wünschte es hätte sich ein bisschen nach unten
verändert, hatte es aber noch, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder übel?
Nein, ich habe Schmerzen im Bein.
Okay, okay, also wie ich gesagt habe,
das ist Routinefragen und deshalb wollte ich fragen
und ich möchte über Ihr Algermannszustand
eine Frage erstellen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Schmerzen beim
tiefen Lagern verbessert, oder?
Ja, wenn ich den Nachts das Gefühl habe,
dass das nicht so gut ist, dass das irgendwie ein bisschen
öffnet, dann ist das besser, wenn ich mich auf die
Bettkante setze.
Okay, Bettkante sitzen noch besser.
Okay, okay.
Aber das sind noch nicht so richtige Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen habe ich nur beim Laufen, aber wenn ich das Gefühl habe,
dass das sich komisch anfühlt, also ungewöhnlichheit.
Okay, okay, aber bei ein bisschen kälter oder so.
Okay, okay, sehr viel.
Ich verstehe gut.
Und Herr Weber, haben Sie irgendeine chronische
Erkrankungen wie?
Die ganze Latte, in meinem Alter ja kein Wunder.
Also ich habe natürlich Bluthochdruck,
dann habe ich schon seit zehn Jahren.
Und ich bin auch Diabetiker, das auch schon viel länger,
schon 25 Jahre.
25 Jahre, okay.
Meinen Sie, die haben ich weich, oder?
Bitte?
Meinen Sie, Diabetes Militär?
Ja.
Okay, seit fünf Jahren.
Und ja, der Hausarzt hat auch festgestellt,
dass ich zu Ruhe Blutfettwerte habe.
Da muss ich eigentlich auch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und ja, vor sechs Jahren habe ich auch richtig
ein Reingegrichter, habe ich ein Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Aber da habe ich mich zum Glück guter von erholt.
Also, wann war der Herzinfarkt vor sechs Jahren?
Das ist sechs Jahre her.
Okay, sechs Jahre.
Wie wurde das behandelt?
Also, ja, ich habe da so einen Stand bekommen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und erhörte Blutfettwerte auch seit sechs Jahren?
Ja, die habe ich wahrscheinlich schon länger,
aber da hat man das halt festgestellt.
Nicht sehr, aber seit schon langes Zeit haben sie.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Okay, okay.
Ja, also, das ist bei uns auch in der Familie,
dass mein Vater hatte auch ein Herzinfarkt,
wahrscheinlich hatte er auch erhieltem Blutfettwerte.
Ja, der Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt erlitten?
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, aber ihr Vater lebt noch, oder?
Nein, nein, er ist da dran gestorben.
Ja, das ist schon lange her.
Okay, wegen des...
Ich bin ja schon 64, ich bin ja schon 64.
Mein Vater, der ist da von 19 über 19.
Ja, ich verstehe, aber er tut mir leid,
ja, richtig, Herr Weber, ja, das ist eine
effektige Situation.
Also, das Herzinfarkt, ist ihr Vater gestorben, oder?
Der ist am Herzinfarkt gestorben, ja.
Okay, okay, gut.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also mir reicht es komplett, was ich so habe, ne.
Ich hatte noch einen Bandscheibenvorfall,
der ist aber operiert worden,
das ist so zwölf Jahre her.
Ja, ja, mein Beruf muss man manchmal schwer heben
und arbeiten, dann ist das halt passiert.
Ja, ich bin Kraftfahrer, also Lkw-Fahrer.
Grad oder Lkw-Fahrer, okay.
Also, Sie arbeiten noch, also Sie sind nicht retten.
Ja, ich bin jetzt demnächst komme ich in Rente,
aber noch muss ich arbeiten, ja.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Okay.
Und, Bandscheibenvorfall,
in welchem Bereich, in Nacken oder in Ländernbereich?
Ne, in...
und weiter unten, also,
ja, in unteren, unteren, unteren Ländern.
Okay, in Ländern, unteren Ländern.
Okay, bereit.
Und, also, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Also, haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme
wegen der Bandscheibenvorfall-Operationen?
Ne, das ist Gott sei Dank auskuriert
und da habe ich jetzt keine Schwierigkeiten.
Ja, das freut mich sehr gut.
Okay, okay.
Und, Sie, haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein.
Zum Glück nichts weiter sonst.
Okay, nur diese Vorerkrankungen und die Operationen.
Okay.
Ja, wobei nur ist gut, das sind ja eine ganze Menge Vorerkrankungen.
Ja, ja, eigentlich für diese Alte, ja, sieht alles gut, ja,
machen Sie keine Sorgen, okay.
Und Sie nehmen auch, ich glaube, regelmäßig Medikamente ein, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Gegen der Blutdruck muss ich etwas nehmen,
für den Diabetes muss ich etwas nehmen.
Okay.
Und Aspirin nehme ich auch für das Herz, ne?
Ja, Herz, ja, gegen Herz.
Okay, wir spielen jetzt über Ihr Medikament an.
Und Sie mir sagen, welche Medikamente einnehmen?
Ja, also ich nehme Ramipril für den Blutdruck
oder gegen den Wohnenblutdruck.
Da nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und der Zucker, das ist ja auch eine Art,
und der Zucker, das ist nicht so schlimm,
das ist eigentlich immer ganz gut in der Grundtakontrolle.
Da muss ich nur einmal am Tag Med-formin nehmen.
Und Aspirin, da nehme ich auch eine morgens.
Eine morgens, okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay, das ist alles.
Ich möchte ein bisschen vertiefen über Ihr Medikament an der Mese,
Herr Weber. Ramipril, wissen Sie, welcher Dosierung ist?
Ich meine, da steht Ramipril 100 auf der Packung, ja.
100 mg.
Okay, Ramipril Tabletten 100 mg.
Und Med-formin, wie viel Milligramm?
Das ist Med-formin 500, das weiß ich sicher.
500 und morgens oder abends, was nehmen Sie?
Die nehme ich morgens.
Okay.
Spitzen Sie Insulin?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist kein, ich habe den schon lange diesen Diabetes,
aber das ist kein, also das ist noch nicht so schlimm.
Okay, okay.
Sie gehen regelmäßig zum Kontrolle,
also ich glaube, ja, regelmäßig so gut wie das geht bei meinem Beruf.
Da ist es ein bisschen schwierig, zum Arzt zu kommen.
Okay, aber Sie haben keine Probleme mit Bluthochdruck oder Diabetes.
Ich hoffe nicht, ja.
Okay, wann haben Sie letzte Kontrolle gemacht?
Das ist schon eine Weile her, bestimmt im halben Jahr.
Ein halbes, okay, ja.
Okay, und Aspirin, welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Ja, Aspirin 100 ist das immer, ne?
100, ja.
Okay, das ist alles.
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Und haben Sie irgendeine Allergien?
Ich meine Gräser oder Haustop, Medikamenten?
Nein, nee.
Aber warten Sie mal, ich habe mal Pinizilien bekommen.
Das ist mir gar nicht bekommen.
Ich erinnere mich jetzt dran.
Okay.
Wie euch setzt sich diese Allergie?
Ja, da habe ich irgendwie so ein ganz rotes Gesicht bekommen.
Das war ganz unangenehm.
Okay, rötliches Gesicht und Hautausschlag vielleicht?
Ja, das hat auf gejuckt, das war ganz unangenehm.
Okay, okay.
Wann haben Sie Pinizilenergie bemerkt?
Oh, das ist schon richtig lange her.
Normalerweise braucht man ja sowas nicht, aber da musste ich mal wegen einer Krankheit behandelt werden.
Das ist irgendwie nicht besonders gut gewesen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Hatten Sie ein Atemnot, wie zum Beispiel erinnern Sie?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Nee, so schlimm war das nicht.
Aber der Arzt hat mir gesagt, wenn ich das nochmal bekommen könnte, das passieren.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Hautausschlag, rötliches Gesicht und Hautausschlag.
Okay, das ist alles.
Wir kommen, wenn Sie zum Beispiel Brot oder Milchprodukte essen.
Nein, nein, nein, ich kann alles essen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Herr Weber, können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie rauken?
Ja, ich rauche ordentlich.
Was müssen Sie, wenn man LKW fährt?
Was soll man am ganzen Tag machen?
Ein Päckchen am Tag rauche ich schon, ja.
Ein Päckchen, ja.
Das kann gut verstehen.
Sie leiden unter einem bisschen Stress und deswegen brauchen Sie etwas rauchen.
Ja, und auch, ja.
Damit die Zeit besser umgeht.
Okay.
Was seid man, rauchen Sie, Herr Weber?
Ach, schon als ich ein junger Mann war, also bestimmt 40 Jahre.
Seit 40 Jahren.
Okay.
Sie meinen 20 Zigaretten in eine.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das kann ich mir selbst,
als LKW-Fahrer nicht gut erlauben.
Wenn ich mal ein freies Wochenende habe oder wenn mal etwas zu feiern ist,
dann gibt es schon mal einen Schluck, aber nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Was trinken Sie?
Bier, Bier oder auch mal ein Schnaps dabei.
Je nachdem, was es gerade so gibt.
Okay, aber das ist nur gelegentlich.
Am Wochenende oder Feier.
Ja, also nicht jeden Tag.
Wie gesagt, ich muss ja auch mal ein Schnaps geben.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Und ja, diese Frage ist, Routine Frage, Herr Weber.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie davor konsumiert?
Ach nein, nein, nein.
Manchmal denkt man zwar, wenn man so müde ist,
dass man vielleicht mal etwas gerne nehmen würde,
aber nein, ich habe das nie probiert.
Okay, okay.
Sehr gut.
Das ist sehr gut.
Und Sie arbeiten als LKW-Fahrer.
Ja, genau.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Oh, sorry.
Ja, ja, ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind schon groß, ne?
Aber vier Kinder haben sie ja.
Ach so, sehr gut.
Sind Sie gesund?
Wir sind alle gesund, ja.
Okay.
Und, Lebt ihr Muttern noch?
Ja, aber die ist sehr pflegebedürftig.
Also, der geht es nicht gut.
Die hat auch, die hat auch, genauso wie ich,
eben diese Zuckerkrankheit,
die ist ein Alterszucker.
Und er ist natürlich jetzt auch schon hoch betagt.
Die ist pflegebedürftig, ja.
Ja, ich kann gut verstehen.
Okay, und aber, ja, jetzt Sie nehmen regelmäßige Medikamente ein
und Sie sind teilweise gesund, oder wie ist jetzt Ihr Mutter?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, die ist halt, die ist halt alt und pflegebedürftig, ne?
Okay.
Aber sie ist in einem Heim untergebracht und wird da gut versorgt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay.
Okay, ja Herr Weber.
Ich denke, ich habe für mich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Okay, möchten Sie ergänzen oder haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich jetzt gerne wissen,
woran es liegt, dass mein Bein so weh tut und was man dagegen tun kann.
Ja, ja, okay.
Denn das geht ja so nicht weiter.
Ich muss ja mal ein bisschen laufen können.
Ja, ja, das ist eine heftige Situation.
Ich kann gut verstehen Herr Weber.
Ja, bisher haben wir nur das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Deshalb, ja, kann ich nicht, ja, so viel sagen, aber ja, der Bestät,
also der Bestät, also Bein Bestät der Verdacht auf eine Arterienerkrankung,
also das...
Meine Arterien sind krank.
Es kann sein, wie ich gesagt habe, wie ich gesagt habe,
wir haben das Analysegespräch gemacht.
Wie kann man das denn jetzt feststellen, was da ist?
Ja, ja, ich...
Als erstes mache ich sie körperlich untersuchen, okay?
Und sie untersuchen nicht körperlich?
Ja, danach mache ich eine Labordiagnostik
und ich brauche ein paar medizinisches Verfahren wie Sonografie,
also das...
Und tut das weh?
Nein, machen Sie keine Sorgen, das ist Routineverfahren,
ist ein bisschen speziell zu dieser Verdacht,
das wird als Doppler Sonografie oder...
Ja, da kann ich mir nichts drunter vorstellen.
Ja, Doppler Sonografie.
Das ist wie eine Ultraschalluntersuch,
aber noch speziell Ultraschalluntersuch.
Wissen Sie, Ultraschalluntersuch...
Haben Sie das Rheinbelastung?
Nein, nein.
Hier handelt es um keine Strahlungbelastung, okay?
Ja, mit einem Geräte, also machen wir diese Untersuchung.
Und Sie sagen, das ist keine Strahlung
und es tut nicht weh?
Ja, richtig.
Ja, das ist gut, dann können Sie etwas ruhig machen mit mir.
Ja, machen Sie keine Sorgen, richtig.
Routine und Schmerzfreies, das ist eine sehr gute Performance, okay?
Dann schauen wir mal, wie wir weiter vorgehen wollen.
Okay, dann hoffe ich ja mal, dass das bald alles besser ist.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Okay, vielen Dank für alle Komissionen.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Ich denke, es gibt keine Frage mehr durch die Terne.
Ich habe mir auch nicht vorgestellt, er hat so viele Fragen gestellt.
Ja, aber ich habe vergessen, also ich wollte am Ende auch fragen,
aber ich habe nicht gemacht.
Vielleicht wäre besser, die Fragen zu stellen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion ausstrahlen beim Laufen?
Ach so, nein, strahlen aber nicht rein.
Nein, okay.
Ja, ich glaube auch, das war eine sehr komplette Analyse.
Ja.
Der Patient, wenn ich das so genau wüsste, der Patient war ja auch sehr gesprächlich.
Ja, ja, ja, das war ein bisschen wichtig.
Und sie haben aber auch wirklich alles gefragt, was man in den Zusammenhang fragt.
Ja, ich glaube, diese Schmerzen waren unterschenkt, oder?
Ja, ja.
Aber ich habe nicht gefragt, ob es besser wäre, um das zu stellen.
Ja.
So hat die Frage gestellt, unsere Kollegen, wo ist der Schmerz genau in Ihrem Bein?
Ja, das hat er jetzt gerade nochmal recht auf uns erschenkt, ne?
Ja.
Also in der Warte überwiegend, ne?
Ja, ich denke nicht genug.
Es gibt Taubhautgefühl oder Schwellung.
Im Augenblick hat er das nicht bemerkt.
Nein, er wünschte sich vielleicht, dass wäre Taub, damit es nicht so weh tut.
Aber nein, Taubhautgefühl hat er aber nicht gestellt.
Können wir zum zweiten Teil gehen, Rahme?
Ja, nur ein paar Sekunden, dann können wir anfangen.
Aber Gün, es will ein bisschen Speed machen hier.
Ja.
Okay, wir können anfangen.
Guten Tag, Frau Wersten. Darf ich meinen neuen Patienten Herr Weber vorstellen?
Ja, was haben Sie mit dem gemacht? Was ist mit dem los?
Ja, okay.
Ich möchte heute Ihnen gerne einen, also den 64-jährigen Patienten,
Herr Weber vorstellen.
Er ist am 16. April 1958 geboren.
Sehr gut.
Er ist 82 Kilogramm schwer und 1 Meter, 78 groß.
Herr Weber stellte sich heute wegen seit ein paar Tagen bestehende Kreditkassiointernitenz
am rechten Unterschenkel bei uns vor.
Die Patienten bewertete die Schmerzintensität beim Laufen auf eine Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10,
also 6 bis zu 8.
Das muss ich aber noch mal fragen.
Er hat eine Klaudikatio erst seit 3 Tagen?
Seit ein paar Tagen, oder?
Ja, vorher hat er nichts gemerkt.
Nein, nein, also ein 3-Monaten haben die Patienten,
aber seit ein paar Tagen hätten die Beschwerden sich verschlechtert.
Ah, okay, das ist jetzt akutschlechter geworden.
Ja, akute Auftrittende sind starke Kreditkassiointernitzen
seit ein paar Tagen bekannt, aber die Beschwerden,
die Patienten, die krackt sind, sind seit 3 Monaten.
Und die starke Schmerzen sind nach Gehstrecke von 300 m aufgetreten.
Der Patient gab an, dass er an der betroffenen Extremität,
Alopecia und Alopecia-Geländszentren haut,
so wie Kältegefühl hat.
Ja, und die Beschwerden hätten sich beim Sitzenden der Bettkante
noch verbessert.
Ja, hat er denn auch Ruhe schmerzen?
Der Patient klagt über keine Ruhe schmerzen,
die Beschwerden würden nur beim Laufen.
Und die weitere vegetative Anamnese
seit bis auf Obstpation, seit ca. 20 Jahren,
so wie Neuktorie, gelegentliche Neuktorie,
unaufwählig,
Anfallkrankungen, seit 10 Jahren,
eine arterielle Hypertonie, seit 25 Jahren,
ein Diabetes-Militus-Typ 2, seit längerer Zeit,
eine Hyperepidemie bekannt.
Seit 6 Jahren hat der Patient einen Neukatinfarkt erlitten,
deswegen hat er einen Stand bekommen.
Und vor 12 Jahren war der Landeskurs in London operiert.
Die Medikamentanamnese ergab die regelmäßigen Einnahme
von der Prämie-Pril-Tabletten,
mit 100 mg morgens und Abends.
Ich fällt mir gerade auf, Ramipril,
gibt es das überhaupt?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Eigentlich.
Ja, ich habe bemerkt,
bei der Medikamentanamnese,
das waren ein bisschen mehr Ramipril-Pril-Pril
für das 10 mg, glaube ich.
Ja, ich meine 10.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Schreibtjehler hier gewesen.
10 mg, das sagen wir.
Ja, 10, ja, aber deshalb habe ich vielleicht 2 Mal geblieben.
Ja, dass ich das einmal durchgestrichen habe.
Ja, ich glaube, ja.
Okay, ich kann das.
Das ist das.
Okay.
Aber er hat ja auch nur der Patient gesagt.
Ja, und deshalb muss ich sagen, kein Problem.
Und mit Formen für 100 mg morgens,
so wie Aspirin 100 mg morgens.
Der Patient reagiert allergisch auf Penicillin
und er hat das mit Erutem am Gesicht,
Exantem, so wie Piroritus.
Er rauf seit 40 Jahren,
20-Sigaretten pro Tag.
Susietslich trinken,
der Patient gelegentlich am Wochenende
und dann zum Beispiel den Schnapp,
den Rogenkonsum,
der Arbeiter als LKW-Fahrer,
der Zahirfeirat, der Zwei-Kinder,
der Fiat-Kinder.
Also,
das betrifft die Familienanmese,
sein Vater an einem Jokatinfarkt verstorben,
seine Mutter sei pflegebedürftig,
weil sie an einem Diabetes-Militus-Sypto-Vy leiden.
Ja, und die ist ja wahrscheinlich auch hoch betagt, die Mutter.
Wenn der schon selber 64 ist,
dann ist die Mutter ja auch in hohem Alter.
Ja, okay.
Und der Patient habe keine Geschwister.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, ja, also aufgrund der bisherigen Anamnesenangaben
gehe ich von einer periferearteriellen
Verschusskrankheit aus.
Welchen Stadion?
Welchen Stadion? Stadion 2a.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie mit den Patienten zunächst?
Also, als erstes nötig der Patient in Körperunterzungen.
Meine Differenzialdiagnose lautet,
als erstes TVT.
Deshalb würde ich Homas Payer Zeichen überprüfen.
Also, ich würde auch den Patienten inspektieren.
Inspezieren, inspezieren, inspektieren.
Inspezieren, inspezieren, inspezieren.
Okay, inspezieren, inspezieren.
Okay.
Und ich meine, ich würde mit anderem Bein, also,
ich würde Puls, Arterin Puls vergleichen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich meine, vielleicht wissensbeichfülle TV-Alice,
Posterior, oder auch, ja, Femoral Arter,
oder auch Arter vergleichen.
Danach, der Patient hat gesagt, er hat eine Haalopyssey
und ja, Glänzsender Haut, ich würde überprüfen.
Also auch im Vergleich dann, ne?
Und was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Ja, als Labordiagnostik würde ich, ja,
kleines Blutbild, Inszenuzparameter, auch der Demära,
Gerinnungsparameter und ja.
Aufgrund der Vorerkrankungen, oder?
Ja, ja, richtig.
Aufgrund Vorerkrankungen, Lykosischpiegelung,
Lipidparameter, L oder Hdl.
Ja, sehr gut, alles gut.
Und Herzparameter wie Troponin, Te oder CKMB,
Myoglobin, auch.
Alles gut, ja.
Also volle Labordiagnostik für die Vorerkrankung.
Gut, was würden Sie dann operativ machen?
Ja, als operativ diagnostisch würde ich
doppelige Dezimographie drucken.
Genau.
Ja, mit dieser Unterzulung können wir
der Arterien beurteilen, ob bei den Patienten
erstoffte Arterien vorlegt, oder nicht.
Ja, genau.
Ja, können die Gefäßverschulung,
oder Blutstürme messen?
Sehr gut, ja.
Ja.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen,
der hat tatsächlich eine PAVK, was wäre dann die Therapie?
Ja, Therapie.
Therapie richtet sich nach der Stadion.
Nach dem Stadion, ja, richtig.
Also als erstes würde ich Trombose,
Profilaxie, wie Heparin, oder...
Der nimmt ja schon ASS, ne?
Ja, auch, ja, der Patient nimmt auch ASS,
aber auch wir können mit Trombose,
also Profilaxie, wie Heparin,
oder vielleicht Klopidogrel kombinieren.
Okay.
Und auch bei der Infektion,
verdacht, vorlegt, ja, können wir Antibiotik-Therapie auch...
Ja, worauf müssen wir da achten?
Was, wie bitte?
Worauf müssen wir bei der Antibiotik-Therapie achten?
Ja, der Patient reagiert auf Penicillin,
dann wollen wir rett-makulide.
Ja, müssen wir andere, andere, genau.
Wenn er jetzt im Stadion zwei ist,
was würden wir da für eine Therapie ansetzen,
außer zusätzlich zum Klopidogrel oder so?
Ja.
Also wir können den Patienten
konservativ-therapie eigentlich empfehlen.
Ja, richtig.
Was würde dazu gehören?
Was würde zur konservativen Therapie dazu gehören?
Ja, die Konservattherapie besteht auf,
ich zum Beispiel, regelmäßig laufen.
Sehr gut, ja.
Auch besteht aus hintergrund vorliegenden
Vererkrankungen,
Konusche Vererkrankungen zu anzustellen,
wie zum Beispiel Diabetes mei Lütus oder Bluthochdruck
oder Blutfett.
Genau, der bringt ja so viele Risikofaktoren mit.
Ja, das ist ein Risikofaktor.
Und der muss einfach, ja, vielleicht,
was muss er denn noch dringend machen?
Ja, richtig.
Der Patient ja raucht so viel.
Und ja, deshalb eigentlich wird diese Erkrankung
als Raucherbein.
Sehr gut, ja.
Deshalb sollten wir den Patienten
aufrauchen.
Zum Nikotinkarrenz auffordern.
Ja, Nikotinkarrenz, ja.
Wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass er sich daran hält?
Wie bitte?
Das ist der Chance, dass er das macht,
auf Nikotin zu verzichten.
Ja.
Sehen Sie das?
Haben wir da gute Chancen, dass dieser Patient nicht weiter raucht?
Also, denke, ja, der Patient kann es schaffen,
aber das war ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen, der raucht seit 40 Jahren.
Ja, aber...
Der Herzinfarkt hat ihn nicht davon abgehalten.
Ja, das riecht aber.
Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, wie
Therapie,
Applietung, wie zum Beispiel
Pulmonel, Applietung oder so.
Ähnlich oder der Patient kann auch
Nikotin-Pflaster benüssten, vielleicht.
Ja, ja, aber er muss es wollen, ne?
Das ist das Entscheidende.
Ja.
Was würden Sie der Medikamentös im Stadium 2
vielleicht noch zusätzlich machen?
Mhm.
Also, zusätzlich die Therapie mit Kamenten.
Was ist das?
Denken Sie mal an die Blutfette.
ACM, oder?
Statine.
Statine, ja, richtig, natürlich.
Ja.
Wobei, ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt die Klammer aufklame,
das ist nicht unumstritten, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Hier ist es erwähnt in diesem Fall,
aber ich glaube, das ist unter
Fachleuten, ist die Stadiengabe gar nicht unumstritten.
Ja.
Wir gucken, was gerade Lehrmeinung ist.
Ja, ja, ich habe mich jetzt erinnert.
Ja, Statine kann man jede Stadion verordnen.
Ja, das ist, ja, richtig, Sie haben recht.
Gut, was ist denn im Stadium 3?
Wo fängt das Stadium 3 denn an?
Stadium 3, also beide Stadium 3 handelt
erst um eine, wie kann man sagen,
Stürme, also man, Blutstürme, also Tropiche,
Tropiche, Blutstürme.
Profisse, Profisse, Profisse, die Runde haben wir im Stadium 4.
4.
Weil, weil Stadium 3 haben wir die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen, genau.
Ja, ja, ja, die Schmerzen.
Und, ja, da müssen wir dann auch was tun,
da müssen wir, was käme da als,
als Therapieverfahren zum Einsatz?
Wenn wir Stadium, wenn wir ein Dreier Stadium haben,
was machen wir dann?
Ja, dann, ja, wir können die Medikamente Therapie anstellen.
Ja, da müssen wir schon ein bisschen handgreiflicher werden.
Was müssen wir machen oder könnten wir machen?
Stadium 3.
Dreier Stadium ist operationsbedürftig.
Ja, wie zum Beispiel Revascularisation oder...
Revascularisation, genau, PTA, ne?
Ja, PTA, Stabgenase.
Entweder PTA oder Beipassopie oder was auch immer,
wo der Verschluss sitzt.
Gut, und dann haben wir das 4er Stadium,
haben wir das, was Sie eben sagten, die tropischen Störungen.
Oder Kangren.
Und haben unter bestimmten Negrosen,
müssen dann also auch zum Äußerstreiten
unter Umständen geliebt werden, amputieren.
Und haben es immer mit schlechten Heilenden Wunden
natürlich zu tun.
Ja, gut.
Ja, perfekt.
Ja, aber bei diesen Patienten sind wir ja maximal im 2A-Stadium.
Ja, richtig.
Der kann ja noch 300 Meter Schmerz freilaufen.
Das heißt, da würde man tatsächlich, ja,
vielleicht nochmal gucken, dass man...
einfach die Risikofaktoren noch runter setzt,
dass er in seinem Leben still ein bisschen was arbeitet.
Und dann könnte man noch eben
Statine geben und Getraining.
Das haben Sie aber sehr, sehr schon wunderbar gesagt.
Perfekt. Also ich glaube, dieser Patient wird von Ihnen
sehr, sehr gut versorgt.
Halten Sie mich, wie immer, auf dem Laufenden,
was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rausgekommen ist.
Ja?
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, alle sind erschrofft,
weil Sie haben alles gesagt, also völlig erschöpft.
Ja?
Es ist nix schuldig geblieben.
Nix.
Dankeschön.
Wahnsinn.
Ja.
Wann ist Prüfung?
Freitag.
Ja.
Locker, locker-flok.
Ich mache Ihre Prüfung.
Ja, einige Punkte.
Aber okay, kein Problem.
Das kann sein.
Aber sprachlich würde ich sagen,
habe ich neulich schon gesagt, Sie sind ein bisschen fix unterwegs.
Aber das werden Sie auch in der Prüfung sein.
Einfach der Aufregung geschuldet.
Ich glaube, das ist müßig, wenn ich Ihnen jetzt sage,
machen Sie ein bisschen langsamer.
Ja?
Ja.
Aber Sie sind sprachlich wirklich sehr, sehr sicher unterwegs.
Und das glaube ich, dass ich keine Sorgen habe.
Dankeschön.
Vielen Dank für alle Informationen.
Das war sehr gut für mich heute.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ich hoffe, dieser Fall kommt am Freitag, Dr. Rahme.
Ja, ich wünsche Ihnen einen netten Beer vor K-Patienten.
Oder einfach 5-Tan-Ten-Fall.